so the heading is percentage increase
and decrease and to explain what we're
going to do today I have some pictures
you know how much I love pictures now
there are two big reasons why it's
important to look at percentage increase
and decrease and here's the first
obvious reason percentage increase and
decrease you will encounter them over
and over and over again throughout your
life every single day you're going to be
encountering things that I'm gonna move
this down just a little bit so you can
see anything that presents you with
percentages that will increase something
or decrease something you'll see them
all the time and you will be expected no
one's gonna hold your hand and tell you
the right answer you just kind of got to
work out what it is that they mean even
when some of the percentages are like
what does it mean to get 80 state
hundred seventy-five percent of my a
daily value of vitamin K what's that
supposed to mean okay
it is a lot now here's my first reason
right you're going to encounter
percentage increase in decrease all the
time this is something really relevant
but just as important
number two percentage increase in
decrease are famously confusing and to
illustrate that I'll put this back up
next on O'Neal to illustrate that I'd
like you all to have a go at solving
this puzzle if you think you have an
answer don't spoil it
maybe call mrs. Lee's or I over to have
a look but all the information that you
need is here you've got some potatoes
and peas errors by the way are
incredibly filled with mainly water I
know it's actually not exactly this
percentage but it is a very high
percentage much higher than you would
think
you leave your potatoes out in the Sun
and then they get dried out until such a
point as there's less water in them
there are the 98 percent so now my
question is if you started with a
hundred kilos how much do you end with
I'd love to see some working and if you
think you haven't answered don't call it
out let everyone else have their process
to think about it I'm gonna give you
about three minutes to have a play with
it good luck off you go
you have just wonderfully Illustrated
for me what my second point was right I
said percentage increase in decrease we
care about it number one because it
comes up a lot all the time in real life
and number two because they are famously
confusing I've had a range of answers
from you I've had 99 I've heard ninety
eight point nine nine I've heard ninety
seven point o-- two do you want to give
me another answer I've heard a hundred
it's not a hundred okay let me
illustrate to you what's going on let's
this back up for a second okay and this
is not just an illustration in
percentages but also an illustration
just mathematical problem solving in
general right there's a lot of
information here let's step through it
slowly and make sure we digest
everything properly pardon the pun
you've got a hundred kilograms of
potatoes which are 99% water now I got a
really great question from Leah she said
do you mean 99 percent in weight which I
guess the opposites that would be in
volume
I guess lovely question you yourselves
can answer that question from the
context do you think it's weight or do
you think it's volume it's weight isn't
it the way you can guess that is that
there's nothing really in the question
that tells you other things about volume
so if it were volume if that were
actually true then we're kind of stuck
we can't really harder the question so
it is weight now think about that with
me if 99% of and I'm using all of our
language from percentage of quantity
from before right all of that 100
kilograms is water 99% of the 100
kilograms is water so how much what
quantity of the potatoes right now is
water ninety nine kilograms very good
okay so ninety nine kilograms are water
all right think think think think the
rest of it I guess we would call it
solid what's the rest of it then going
to be what weight is left behind what
message is it
there's this one kilogram of solids left
are you okay with that that okay right
so that's how we start that's how we
begin and then the potatoes are left out
in the Sun and they get dry now just
think about this right they dry until
they are 98% water tell me what happens
to this as it dries nothing happens to
this as it dries because this is dry
stuff it's dry right this is what
changes do you agree with that you agree
with that okay no hold on a second wait
you're eight you're still not quite
there yet you're right some of you were
there but others of you are not so I
want to make sure we all get there
together okay they left out to dry and
then this one kilogram right it used to
be 1% of all of the potatoes used to be
1%
it's not 1% anymore is it look at the
question what is this one kilo what is
it now look carefully what percentage is
this of that this is 2% now isn't it
after everything's dried out this
becomes 2% how did you know that there's
no two percent of the question for
Charcot how did you see it
right 99% water 1% solid if it's 98%
water it's 2% so do you agree with that
okay so 2 percent of now I actually
don't know I don't know how many killers
there are in the NSTIC question question
right so I'm just gonna give it a name
I'm gonna call it let's call it P for
potatoes right PE videos right there P
Keeler's left and we know how many there
should be right how many kilos there are
at the end how many kilos are there this
is the solid stuff right this is the
solid stuff this is the solid stuff
there's one kilogram right there okay
now I'm going to call on our ability to
write things not just as percentages but
we can write these in other forms too
right we could write this as for example
a fraction what would two percent be is
a fraction 2 over a hundred this all
this is actually an operator right plus
minus times divide which one is it
it's times there's P the amount of kilos
of potatoes and the answer is one you
care about
now someone already called out oh I can
write two of 100 in a simpler way can I
write that as a simple fraction 1 over
50 very good equals 1 so here's the
amount of the potatoes at the end what
do I do to both sides to get pink eye
I'm going to multiply by 50 which gives
me the final mass now hold on a second
we only try it out a little bit didn't
we we only dried out so that there were
98 percent water rather than 99 does it
sound like they changed very much did
they but in fact the maths of it makes
it very clear sentence this is my point
right percentages are quite
counterintuitive people famously have
trouble when they reason with
percentages what's why we had such a
range of different answers and
eventually you just started throwing
guesses at me you're like I don't know
19 19 who knows right percentages
requires some very careful thought